[Musique]
salut
j'avais que rien c'est heureux de me
retrouver alors les cas rien de ce soir
sans jeannette bougrab
jamais de bonsoir vous êtes avocate
maître de requêtes au conseil d'état ex
présidente de la halde ex secrétaire
d'état à la jeunesse de nicolas sarkozy
et vous êtes ici ce soir pour l'affirmer
haut et fort oui on peut réussir dans la
vie en s'appelant jeannette
dans tous les cas vous représentez un
formidable espoir pour toutes les hub
est dans toutes les pires est toute
récente one est
également avec nous ce soir jean jacques
bourdin
alors jean jacques de s'initier avec
succès sur rmc bfmtv rmc découverte vous
êtes le roi des questions qui tuent vous
poseriez questions à françois hollande
pour le piéger le nom de son premier
ministre
bonne question c'est la bonne question
avec nous également en toile de fond
antoine bonsoir alors le vendredi 22
février à 21h vous présenterez sur canal
en clair la 38e nuit des césars en
direct du théâtre du châtelet c'est la
neuvième fois vous n'avez jamais été
tenté d'en piquer un parce que si vous
attendez qu'ils vous le donne
si j'en ai subtiliser quelques
interviews faciaux évidemment bon pied
des tables basses six mois on paie 3
après le zapping et gaspard proust nous
acquérons notre invité du samedi 20
heures ce soir françois gabart
le vainqueur du dernier vendée globe
voilà l'émission s'appelle salut les
terriens et le groupe
jean jacques bourdin re bonsoir votre
souvenir d'enfance remontent à août
1958 vous avez neuf ans vous regardez
les adultes partir à l'enterrement de
votre grand-père ou plus exactement le
second mari de votre grand mère
maternelle ce papy qui venait vous
cherchez à la sortie de l'école et qui
vous emmenez vos cafés empire alès
je vais essayer sur des moquettes en
moleskine un rouge j'étais invité à la
table des adultes qui buvaient du bir b
y2 rh
font ces 228 a vaincu de là vient sans
doute le besoin chaque matin où que je
sois en france d'aller pousser la porte
d'un café pour écouter les gens les
rencontrer c'est vrai ça c'est vrai bien
des années plus tard et après une
adolescence très alcoolisé d'un peu
alcoolisé vous un peu beaucoup j'ai fait
une crise de tétanie oui bien sûr j'ai
fait un peu d'hôpital c'est vrai j'avais
19 ans s'est offert un point commun
alors après une adolescence très
alcoolisé majoritairement consacrée au
poker et quelques jobs pas très
galvanisant comme placer d'assurance vie
pour lui à mai exactement à 0 1 fabienne
votre petite amie de l'époque vous
présente son oncle qui raymond castans
le directeur des programmes de rtl et
vous le bluffer en lui soutenant que
franco bitossi oui le coureur cycliste
italien n'avait pas été champion du
monde et franco bitossi qu'on appelait
le coureur au coeur fou il avait le
coeur qui s'emballait way en pleine
course et parfois ils étaient obligés de
s'arrêter et d'attendre que son que love
son rythme cardiaque corps deviennent
normal ils auraient dû faire équipe avec
armstrong oui oui c'est aussi l'autre
cas qu une couille
antoine de courtiser moi qui disais
alors qu'à ce temps vous promet un sage
est effectivement en juin 1975 alors que
vous avez déjà quitté ses nièces ils
vous appellent à alès 1 samedi est
complètement dans notre appareil de
lundi et j'arrive au petit matin à paris
gare d'austerlitz et je prends un petit
hôtel à 30 francs la nuit je me souviens
avec wc sur le palier et puis je pousse
la porte de rtl que je ne connaissais
absolument pas ce que j'ai refusé oui
vous écoutiez rmc toute la journée exact
et rtl 2 lits restait 26 ans et j'y
reste 26 ans
comment avec un tati c'est que lui il a
été garçon de café vendeur de voitures
et finalement tous les deux vous avez
plutôt fait l'école de la vie que
l'école de journalisme a totalement
c'est un truc à dire aux gens qu'ils
valaient journalistes ne fête nationale
j allais dans les bistrots
au moins nous ne sommes pas formaté
alors c'était un tir que vous lancerez
l'interactivité avec les auditeurs ont
la parole était mal vu dans la salle de
rédaction we have all des
s'était tu donne la parole à l'extrême
droite de la parole à l'extrême gauche
toujours à ceux qui protestent mais à
quoi ça sert les journalistes étaient
dépossédés de leurs prérogatives en fait
en arrivant j'étais très mal vue mal
oui c'est vrai alors aujourd'hui une
interactivité est passé dans les mains
vous la pratiquez tous les matins sur
rmc de 6h à 10h sur rmc découvertes
nouvelles chaînes de la tnt va être 7h
et 8h30 oui lance une chaîne chapelle
découverte qui diffuse une émission de
radio tout le monde que les puits disant
c'est pas très cohérent quoi
alors de 8h30 à 9h c'est sur bfm tv qu
est l elysée votre fameuse interview
politique et les politiques ont
tellement peur de vos caisses noires
d'horaires il paraît que même pour
bonjour comment ça va ils demandent à
leur conseiller en communication cell
non non et non pas voulait terroriser
les lots non non mais s'il ya des
émissions comme ça qui font très peur et
vous en fais un bon outil alors
justement entre bourdin a pâti elkabbach
vous préféreriez aller chez qui
alors pour vous j'aime bien le cas
bâches et attirées par le pouvoir au
service des pouvoirs depuis tant
d'années qu'il a une conception du
journalisme que je ne partage pas mais
j'ai une grande admiration pour jean
pierre elkabbach si vous savez pourquoi
parce qu'il dure et quelqu'un qui dure
non ne peut pas être mauvais et voilà il
ya le câblage c'est très indépendant
vis-à-vis des politiques de gauche
alors la pub de rmc vous présente comme
un homme libre oui je l'assumé ouais je
revendique alors vous révéler qu aurélie
filippetti est en vacances à l'île
maurice pour noël malgré les consignes
de françois hollande oui vous énervez
contre valérie pécresse qui nous a
planté un matin maintenant t'es pas un
matin il m'a planté à 00h15 j'ai pas
aimé sincèrement je n'ai pas été appelé
piano responsable de bray
demandé aussi à venice hortefeux ces
deux hommes qui s'embrassent devant lui
cette chaîne bah oui faut assumer si ça
le gêne qu'il le dire ces hommes qui
s'embrassent saddam
il était gêné
et quand jean jacques a voulu
l'embrasser il n'a pas voulu ça c'est
hortefeux
vous en prenez aussi à sophie de menthon
et franck tanguy qui se sont lâchés sur
l'antenne de rmc sur nafissatou diallo
il a dit nafissatou diallo pour une
fille qui sait pas lire pas écrire ac
est moche comme un cul gagner un million
et demi c'est bien c'est vraiment ces
monstres
seniors
sophie de montady l'agression sexuelle
de dsk c'est ce qui pouvait lui arriver
de mieux
c'est pire encore sophie de menthon ce
qui est pire c'est qu'elle n'assume pas
alors que tanguay a assumé mais si un
habitant avait dit ça serait
immédiatement donc on peut pas tout dire
enfin si si tant qu'on est dans le cadre
de la loi et se fit de menton qui
imagine si elle reçoit les bogdanoff
alors jacques vous êtes spécialiste des
questions un peu tordu un le nombre de
sous-marins nucléaires en france mais ça
c'est vieux le nombre de joueurs en
équipe de handball est la différence
entre les chiites et sunnites questions
que j'avais posée à nicolas sarkozy lors
de la présidentielle de 2007 sur
laquelle il avait pédaler pardonnez moi
dans la choucroute alors ce qui est très
marrant c'est que j'avais une autre
question mon cher antoine comme quoi tu
une espèce de prémonition quelle est la
différence entre igor et grichka
bogdanoff
alors quelles questions gênantes vous
poseriez un jeune est son portable
06 son portable pourquoi pas oui mais
mais non je sais pas comme ça je sais
pas ce que je suis je suis très timide
et ses lettres je suis traité pour
l'impressionnante une habitude il
passait comme ça alors jeannette quelles
questions gênantes vous poseriez à
jean-jacques
je pense qu'il vivait très seul c 'est
pas presque et non parce que quand un
livre devenu zéro de la litterna non
mais non pardon je voulais dire seul
seul dans son métier dans la vie vos
rapporteurs nivard et non après non mais
je pense que quand vous tenez ces propos
y compris sur jean pierre elkabbach la
profession ne doit pas être tendre avec
vous vous rendrez pas moi je ne suis pas
avec elle à l'argent réel vous excellez
dans les questions politiquement
concrète
on va faire une interview politique au
contraire
oh
dans quel parti politique avez-vous le
plus d'amis je n'ai pas d'amis dans les
partis politiques quel est l'homme
politique qui vous détestent plus
les hommes politiques
très conservateur traditionnel
j'ai vu marine le pen le jour vous êtes
ont gueulé là alors on s'est engueulé ça
peut arriver parce que collard avait dit
quand on colle h&m pas ouais
celle de viol oui j'aime pas parce que
c'est un jeu plus c'est plus sérieux
mais la politique c'est quelque chose de
sérieux
jean-jacques quel cadeau d'un politique
avez vous déjà refusé je n'en ai jamais
eu et je ne déjeune jamais avec les
politiques jeannette peu témoigne on n'a
jamais déjeuné ensemble pourtant ce
n'est pas l'envié qui vous manque de
désir mais mes chaussures péché bas je
comprends et avec quelle loi récente
êtes vous d'accord
le mariage pour tous
êtes vous dérangé par deux femmes qui
s'embrassent devant absolument pas moi
non plus quel est votre salaire mensuel
vous n'aurez pas là
vous gagnez plus ou moins qu'un ministre
plus
donc plus que 9940 exactement quel est
le montant de la redevance télé ou la la
le montant de la redevance télé sens
180 et quelques noms moi j'accepte ces
131 mais c'est à 21
quel est le prix en kiosque d'un
magazine comme l'express par exemple
4 euros 3 euros 50 c'est pas mal ouais
c'est bien alors pour finir la scène est
horrible
mais bon vous le faites aux autres quel
est le nom du président du niger
alors strictement aucune idée c'est
mamadou issoufou ils sont fous gens fous
merci jean jean nous sommes toujours en
compagnie de jeannette bougrab
le jean jacques bourdin
et d'antoine de caunes
alors jeannette bougrab re bonsoir vous
êtes avocate maître de requêtes au
conseil d'état ex présidente de la halde
ex secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse de
nicolas sarkozy et le 6 mai tout s'est
arrêté le plus dur dans ces cas là c'est
pas savoir quoi faire à 19h30 au lieu
d'aller au grand journal non
non parce que moi j'ai eu la chance
pendant cette période de prendre ce
qu'on appelle un congé d'adoption voilà
donc j'étais assez occupé parce que j'ai
adopté tout seul une petite fille l
arrivée dans ma vie il ya à peu près un
an et je m'étais pas du tout arrêter
alors du coup j'étais j'ai pu profiter
de ma fille vous dites je suis une
célibattante qui a complètement raté sa
vie amoureuse ah oui totalement la
journée pour moi on peut pas sortir du
milieu social dans lequel j'appartenais
fille de harkis dont les parents
savaient pas lire et écrire de
châteauroux 2-2 faire de longues études
j'ai un doctorat j'étais quelques années
maître de conf a pas rien et en plus
essayé d'échapper à sa communauté parce
que je la trouvais parfois étouffante et
un moment on paye toujours l'addition
voilà et cette émancipation ça ne
volonté d'être une femme libre
indépendante et bien sûr le pain avec
une certaine solitude voilà
c'est bien ça me tue
non mais non surtout pas parce que ma
mère elle a dû est marié à 13 ans bon
bah à bientôt 40 ans j'aurai je suis pas
mariée je vais pas m'en plaindre voilà
je peux faire quelque chose bassi
espagnol ça vous dirait je suis et
c'est josé garcia
un enfant mais je crois qu'elle ump un
enfant c'était un papa et de maman
je sais bien je sais bien c'est pour ça
que j'ai toujours été un peu un électron
libre à l'ump - mais je regrette pas un
seul instant à ce que ma fille n'aurait
sans doute pas pu vivre très longtemps
si je l'avais pas adopté et vous savez
que vous soyez dans les pays arabes les
pays africains dans la zee être une
fille c'est déjà mal un tir au départ
adopté une fille pour moi ça avait du
sens
alors en fait depuis le secrétaire
d'état à la jeunesse vous êtes devenu
associé de l'un des plus prestigieux
cabinet d'avocats américain avec pour
mission de développer le business dans
le monde arabe et plus particulièrement
en algérie et ta auquel vous croyez
beaucoup c'est vrai que c'est le dernier
état laïc finalement au maghreb et au
machrek oui c'est vrai parce que c'est
une sorte de village gaulois voisins du
maghreb les gens oublient l'algérie
c'est que l'algérie dans les années ont
fait 90 et le début des années noires
ces trois cent mille morts oui sauf
qu'elle est le prix du terrorisme
islamiste il faut pas oublier que le
maroc s'est figé dick est au pouvoir
c'est le parti justice et développement
ce sont les islamistes il n'y a qu'une
seule femme au sein du gouvernement
marocain elle est voilée est l ennemi
nice la condition des femmes ça juste à
rappeler aux téléspectateurs qu au maroc
quand une fille se fait violer et bien
son violeur peut échapper à une peine de
prison s'ils daignent c'est sympa de sa
part épouser sa victime et donc et l'a
tué lors tunisie j'en parle même pas
parce qu'avec et nate mission avec
l'algérie apparaît aujourd'hui comme le
dernier pays laïc de la région alors
jamais de vous publié chez grasset ma
république se meurt vous mettez en
résonance aux origines votre parcours
avec les problématiques actuelles de la
laïcité en france alors vos origines ma
vous êtes fille de harkis ces soldats
algériens qui avaient choisi la france
et qui malgré ce qui était prévu par les
accords d'evian ont été après
l'indépendance massacrés en algérie et
traités comme des parias en france si je
trouve personnellement que son
comportement aussi ignoble que celui que
la france a eu envers ces juifs qui
s'était battu en 14 18 et qui ont été
déportés pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale moi je me souviens que titine
quand j'étais gamin dans le gard y avait
à coeur de marquer un seul but le coeur
de laudun-l'ardoise il vivait dans des
baraquements il fait très chaud l'été
c'était épouvantable
ce que vous me dites parce que
j'ai fait une émission récemment et on
me disait mais les harkis ont torturé
avec l'armée française quelque part
c'est un attaquant qui a dit ça c'est al
qabas incroyable c'était horrible parce
que ça sous-entend que mon père aurait
pu faire les choses les plus abominables
mon père était dans une armée qui est
énorme et légale a remis la vème
république
c'est le même régiment qui en ce moment
et au mali est ce qu'on va dire que ces
gens là sont des parce que mon père et
arabes donc c'était jeudi je suis
contente pour une fois que mon père qui
est à l' usine dans ton pas très bien et
parle pas très bien français parce qu il
n'entendra pas ce que vous venez de dire
voilà ça m'a fait mal et dans le taxi
qui me ramenait dans mon cabinet
d'avocats eh ben j'ai pleuré puis
comment peut-on dire ça aujourd'hui
comment peut-on dire ça ce sont des
vieux chibanis ce qu'on appelle en arabe
des hommes aux cheveux blancs ils ont
jamais rien eu et quand on commence à le
redire mais ils avaient torturé qu'est
ce que je veux dire c'est pas ce sujet
c'est bien en tous les cas votre
reconnaissance éternelle va nicolas
sarkozy qui a reconnu la responsabilité
de la france dans l'abandon des harkis
donc en 2010 est votre réponse nicolas
sarkozy
oui me demandent de revenir je viens
d'abord je lui ai dit cet été que je
souhaitais pas m'engager en entre copé
et fillon il m'a dit oui chalette mais
tu sais bien alors dans votre bouquin
jeannette vous raconter votre parcours à
l'ump
d expérience politique qui vous ont
parfois laissé un goût amer aux
législatives de 2007 on vous attribue
une circonscription perdue d'avancé
barbès c'est vrai qu'une fille de harki
qui se présentent dans ce haut lieu de
l'indépendance tease main algériens
c'était pas gagné alors j'ai pas gagner
sur les 26 lettres et c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque le secrétaire national de l'ump
la diversité abderrahmane dahmane
vous traite de filles de traître le
vendredi à la mosquée donc ça n'a pas dû
aider non plus non ça peut aider et on a
toujours le sentiment quand on est fille
de harki dette une française de seconde
zone
il apprend ça brice hortefeux dit ce
sont des problèmes entre vous on ne veut
rien savoir c'est des problèmes d'arabes
landes raconté pierre charon le fameux
pierre charon conseiller nicolas sarkozy
qui vous surnomme jamais deux bouts de
gras c'est drôle aussi comme humour
qu'est ce qu'il me le dise c'est sûr
c'est qu'il n'a jamais lui me l'a jamais
dit en phase donc c'est toujours un peu
particulier mais en même temps j'essaie
de perdre du poids je tenais à vous le
dit antoine j'essaye là j'avais un
médecin m'a dit j'ai dix kilos à perdre
comme thierry
alors parler de rachida dati dit des
cheveux courts très noir comme son âme
oui j'ai été déçu par rachida parce
qu'au début vous étiez copine elle vous
raconter ses histoires d'amour et un
jour il a commencé à faire courir le
bruit que vous auriez une aventure avec
nicolas sarkozy et je le dis dans le
livre elle a beaucoup de qualités sert
qu'à une espèce de de force d'abnégation
de capacité à franchir les choses moi je
suis incapable je l'avais interviewé
plein de fonds oui décanter cette fois
c'est avec rachida dati elles attendront
enfin c'est pas une tendre non non mais
enfin bon au delà de ces histoires votre
livre est avant tout un plaidoyer pour
la république vous dites je suis athée
laïque profondément républicaines et
vous vous insurger contre
les exigences du ramadan les créneaux
horaires pour les femmes dans les
piscines le refus des femmes musulmanes
d'être auscultés par des médecins hommes
tout ça ça vous choque mais ça ne choque
ça me choque aussi quand quand le
gouvernement français félicite ennahda
depuis plusieurs mois je dénonce ennahda
parce que je trouve que c'est scandaleux
da selon la constitution que la femme
est le complément de l'homme et vous
dites ça me paraît incroyable qu'une
fille comme diam's veuille être voilée
parce que vous êtes jolie
oui mais célibataire aux petites oeuvres
je peux faire quelque chose pour vous
ces gars là
non mais là ça me donne faim bouchons et
c'est pathétique quand je la vois avec
cette espèce de de drague grill à moi ma
grand mère qui vient des fins fonds là
de bida elle faisait pas ça apporte
affiché à la maison quand elle faisait
la cuisine et quand elle sortait ce
coiffer bien les cheveux comme ça le
mettait une petite barrette faisait un
chignon et et voilà et quand je vois des
filles françaises qui sont nés ici qui
ont tous mais je comprends pas je
comprends pas bref vous n'êtes pas très
halal non mais c'est pas non plus je
suis belge je suis athée chiba gnostique
moi ce que je regrette un peu c'est
qu'en mal à la seprim ben alors la tête
au pakistan j'aurais adoré que tout le
monde descend dans la rue en disant
c'est scandaleux il ya personne et par
contre quand charlie hebdo fait sa une
avec en reprenant la fiche d'un
touchable avec un rabbin qui pousse
animal ça donne lieu à un au pire chose
bravo pour votre courage
antoine de caunes re bonsoir
ça va d'ailleurs j'ai noté nombreux pour
cette émission vous a dit avoir 60 ans
bientôt donc en même temps la fin de
l'année [ __ ] antoine de gaudemar
soissons ça me fait quel âge attend
en tout cas vous ne faites pas antoine
ah mais vous non plus ah ouais ouais
c'est daphné roulier où c'est le vélo
est un mélange des deux on est toujours
fan de lance armstrong pour vous il
reste le plus grand coureur dopé dans ça
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
maintenant j'ai jamais pris un petit
coup dans l'alcool quand même avec la
révélation que tous vous plus être une
révélation je pense que c'est un coureur
exceptionnel un qui est hors norme quoi
voilà donc et toute façon est meilleur
que les autres après il a menti c'est un
proverbe arabe qui dit on c'est pas d'
abou rico un cheval de course
il avait quand même j'avais
jamais comment on reconnaît un coureur
dopé
oui mais je dirais pas ici c'est celui
qui gagne la course
à moi j'ai essayé de faire du vélo
comment toi je compte voilà la ligne qui
là je me suis dit voilà pour moi aussi
mais j'ai peur des piqûres
alors antoine vous animerez le vendredi
22 février à 21h sur canal en clair la
38e nuit des césars en direct du
châtelet voilà c'est la dernière fois
vous dites c'est trop pénible il faut
toujours faire un discours
d'introduction
absolument soporifique c'est parfois
qu'il fait c'est le président wade le
président cette année c'est jamel dans
le discours il a peu de chances d'être
soporifique le dise voilà et en même
temps
c'est un vrai plaisir de travailler sur
cette soirée le plaisir de pervers jeu
j'en conviens mais je sais c'est un
public pas très facile non mais on prend
un plaisir fou avec renault le
producteur a travaillé sur cette soirée
vous allez faire qu'aux membres se
soient pas trop chiant cette année les
césars vous allez montrer des extraits
de films américains
mais je pense que la soirée va être pas
mal quand même alors cette année il ya
un truc nouveau ses deux césar du
meilleur acteur trop payés
fait dany boon
c'est pas des résultats encore si
sûrement ouais y'a le césar du meilleur
acteur exilé fiscal
gestion de la vienne
leur vieux clavier attachera à vous
défendez gérard mais oui je défends avec
châteauroux gérard gachet s'amuser aussi
on est des vrais parution soutien vous
si on n'a pas de chance on n'est pas
beaucoup la vie a été très rude avec
nous
belle soirée en perspective en tout les
43 ça c'est le vendredi donc le dimanche
et les oscars ouais ouais vous
connaissez la différence entre les césar
exauce car
les saf lambert a eu assez de
ces fonds
drôle de nom j'aime bien john de codes
parce qu'il est élégant moi il a
toujours une distance avec les
événements il a un site british way est
il à condition que jean paul gaultier
qui s'appelait eurotrash qui était
absolument génial en kilt dans laquelle
ils ont fait dire à carla bruni qui lui
fait dire à carla voyez comme carla
bruni est polyglotte et qu'à l'époque
elle n'était pas mariée au président de
la république
on lui a fait dire dans toutes les
langues européennes
mais moi un doigt dans le cul
moi je me suis là elle l'a fait c'était
impeccable sur mesure et avec une
délicatesse qui m'a stupéfiée jure mais
c'était très drôle
voilà on passe maintenant dauchez de la
semaine avec l'édito de blacko et c'est
le juge antiterroriste marc trévidic que
nous retrouverons sur ce plateau après
le magnéto
le qatar finance-t-il les terroristes
contre lesquelles les soldats français
se battent au mali c'est en tout cas ce
qu'affirme et l'an dernier le canard
enchaîné cette semaine c'est au tour du
parti socialiste d'exprimer des soupçons
selon harlem désir le qatar doit
clarifier sa position face au terrorisme
il n'est d'ailleurs pas le premier à le
réclamer dans une note confidentielle
publiée en 2010 par le new york times
hillary clinton affirme que l'arabie
saoudite est la principale source de
financement du terrorisme islamiste mais
elle ajoute que le pays qui luttent le
moins contre ce financement celle qatar
du coup on se pose des questions l'émir
du qatar est accueillie chez nous à bras
ouverts pour la même dispensé de payer
des impôts sur ces investissements en
france pas étonnant qu'en plus du psg
puis se soit offert des parts dans
veolia lagardère vivent dix au total
mais là où ça devient ambigu c'est que
le qatar m'investis pas seulement en
france par exemple depuis que les frères
musulmans sont au pouvoir le qatar a
doublé son aide financière à l'egypte
les inquiétantes lors d'une visite
officielle à gaza l'émir du qatar a
signé un chèque de 400 millions de
dollars pour soutenir le hamas où l'on
considère en europe comme un mouvement
terroriste
pauvre émir du qatar on lui reproche des
ambiguïtés n'empêche pendant la guerre
en libye c'était notre seul allié arabe
à l'époque ça nous arrangeait bien que
le qatar financent des groupes
salafistes pour combattre kadhafi mais
maintenant que ces groupes sont
installés au mali comment reprocher au
qatar de leur avoir acheté des armes
d'un côté on reproche au qatar son
indulgence avec les duellistes mais de
l'autre la france soutient sans réserve
les djihadistes lorsqu'ils combattent
bachar el-assad en syrie alors c'est
bien gentil de demander au qatar de
clarifier sa position sur le terrorisme
mais peut-être que la france devrait
elle aussi péri fier sa position voilà
c'était les huit ou neuf l'aco mise en
image de julia rappaz m'attribue dit
bonsoir sept juges d'instruction au pôle
antiterroriste du tribunal de grande
instance de paris et vous publiez
terroristes les sept piliers de la
déraison chez lattès un livre qui est en
tête des ventes bienvenue parmi nous
marque merci alors voilà le sujet de la
semaine là ce sont les révélations du
canard enchaîné et reprise par même
désir concernant le qatar ce petit
émirat très sympa qui a offert aux la
tan et des canaux parisiens mais qui
financerait également des groupes
terroristes islamistes au mali en libye
en syrie est ce que tout ça ne fait pas
de david beckham un terroriste je vous
poserai
rodez par le qatar était un pays que
personne ne connaissait l'émir du qatar
en 95 il arrive en angleterre il montre
ses papiers on lui dit le qatar c'est
quoi donc effectivement il avait envie
de se faire connaître il ya sûrement une
volonté d'exister sur la carte du monde
n'est ya aussi la volonté de penser à
l'avenir c'est à dire que quand les
ressources gazières seront épuisées il
faudra bien vivre de quelque chose donc
ils investissent et c'est vrai que on se
demande si l'un vante pas parallèlement
à ça un djihad sournois c'est ce qu'on
appelle la stratégie du soft power c'est
un type et qui veut certainement étendre
son influence d'abord dans la zone où il
est pour préparer l'avenir mon avis
c'est avant tout avoir une influence sur
la zone géographique sur le moyen-orient
en europe pourquoi pas se faire des amis
un peu partout ça peut aider mais
clairement prendre le leadership sur
cette zone en aidant les groupes qui
renversent des régimes alors je trouve
que les groupes qui ont renversé ces
régimes sont des groupes très
d'islamiser pour pas dire plus et que ça
a été la carte du qatar derrière
l'oreille il favorise les révolutions
arabes à travers de l'argent et puis sa
chaîne de télé aussi al jazira
évidemment mais jazira c'est la première
révolution c'est premier printemps à
dire par rapport à tout ce qui s'est
passé après et je crois que c'est ça
alors le mali c'est plus difficile parce
qu'il ya des gens les tisons ils ont
discuté quand ils ont aidé à renverser
le régime libyen c'est pas parce qu'à un
moment donné les gens qui vous discutez
sont vos amis que vous les finances et
vous allez arrêter tout du jour au
lendemain parce que si ça se passe au
mali c'est pas si simple que ça pour eux
et à tous et toutes ces aides elles sont
vertueuses ou ou vicieuse
il faut quand même pas oublier que c'est
un excellent état qui reste habite mon
mac l'arabie saoudite mais ça reste le
wahhabisme qui a donc des affinités avec
les groupes salafistes ouais à la base
donc vertueux pas vertueux ça dépend de
quel côté ans oui il faut savoir une
chose c'est qu'ils essayent de faire la
même chose en algérie pour déstabiliser
d'algérie ce qu'évidemment el jazeera
une partie est sauf mais il faut écouter
les prêches qui sont faits au kata et il
faut savoir que de nombreux islamistes
algériens conditions sur les mains en
fait sont au qatar aujourd'hui et ont
parfois même des titres des plots matic
cancan l'émir du qatar va à gaza et qui
donne quels 100 millions de dollars pour
les routes et des écoles c'est du pognon
qui peut servir à acheter des armes ça
pour attaquer israël n'ont à mon avis le
qatar joue sur tous les tableaux c est
plein d'informations diverses un moment
donné ils ont malgré des problèmes entre
les sunnites et les chiites il a essayé
de se rapprocher de l'iran malgré tout
certaines derrière ça s'est pas fait je
suis persuadé dans la zone ils doivent
taper à toutes les portes pour essayer
de se faire des amis un peu partout
jouant des double jolie triple jeu donc
voilà ghazala mais à peu près tous les
états de la zone où ils ont dû les
approcher d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est vrai que tu confus que ça
mais gaza c'est très très bien ça c'est
dans l'allier c'est des palestiniens
donc c'est la lignée logique de ce que
doit faire un état arabe donc ça aussi
filer du pognon à netanyahou non oui
voilà pourquoi la exactement tipi livni
là l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères israélienne du parti kadima
le parti centriste kadima a révélé dans
une émission de télévision en israël que
le qatar avait donné de l'argent à
l'extrême droite israélienne c'est à
dire le parti de lieberman est aussi au
likoud de benjamin netanyahu
donc là ça devient extrêmement compliqué
comment on peut donner de l'argent en
même temps or hamas à gaza et à
l'extrême droite israélienne voilà alors
vous dites c'est pour [ __ ] la merde
vous aider à vous rapprocher l'iran ça
c'est connu et peut-être que comme ça a
cassé de façon assez brutale
ils veulent embêter les iraniens on fait
rien la guerre enfin que les
spécialistes voient bien arriver c'est
la guerre entre chiites et sunnites
donc aujourd'hui c'est déstabiliser
toute la régie du tout la région et vous
avez vu il ya quelques mois il ya une
répression en arabie saoudite contre des
chiites donc donc c'est très particulier
et la violence sera celle ci un c'est
aujourd'hui on ne voit que les balbutie
tout petit tout petit c'est peu mais
partout où il ya des vrais problèmes où
il ya le plus de morts de terroristes
d'ailleurs ça reste un pad entre
sunnites et chiites finalement la
question qu'on se pose après avoir
entendu tout ça c est ce qui met des
billes un peu partout pour exister où
est-ce qu'ils ont une stratégie derrière
moi c'est ça qu'est ce que vous en
pensez jean-jacques à moi je crois qu'il
ya une stratégie derrière oui ça c'était
bidon faire tomber les dictateurs laïque
si saint georges est absolument certain
ouais ça je suis absolument certain
qu'il ya cette stratégie là derrière
l'arabie saoudite le qatar absolue dans
certains donc ce sont nos ennemis et
nous a mis en même temps oui de qui se
méfie ton le plus de ses amis ou de ses
ennemis
ce sont nos amis et nos ennemis en même
temps
assez méfiante lasse assez méfiante à
l'égard du qatar je crois pas qu'ils
aient de stratégie je pense que c'est
tout azimut et le qatar achète valentino
achète le psg achète mais si la warner
la chaîne de foot guînes
est ce que c'est une antenne cacher
alors justement bah voilà dans le
dossier qatar gates france football
révèle une réunion entre l'émir du qatar
nicolas sarkozy platini et bazin le
patron du fonds d'investissement colony
qui possédait paris saint germain et ils
ont discuté ce jour-là du rachat du psg
donc par le qatar du capital de
lagardère sa rivale et amie
l'autorisation de sarkozy pour que le
qatar entre pascal eads derrière et
c'est de la création de binh la chaîne
de sport pour déstabiliser canal+ qui
embêtait sarkozy c'est à dire qu'à cause
des guignols on se retrouve à l'exil
quand même et puis l'attribution du
mondial dire que platini lui voulaient
voter pour les états unis et sarkozy et
l'émir l'ont convaincu de voter pour
qatar du châtaignier il ya quelque chose
qui me gêne aussi c'est que le fils de
michel platini dirigea fonds qatari
fonds d'investissement du qatar je note
simplement l'information
ouais oui mais ce que vous ne voyez pas
c'est qu'ils y compris sur bing sport et
donc au début c'est que c'est un produit
d'appel voilà le problème c'est que
racheté les droits de la digue c'est un
moyen de faire venir
at-il attendre qu'ils aient des prêches
la télévision c'est par là qu'on fait
passer un certain nombre de choses et
quand il ya eu le congrès du relief le
dernier congrès quand on est en fin de
compte on donne pas des titres des visas
des visas d'entrée à des types qui font
des prêches des fatwas deux heures par
semaine sur al jazeera dont on peut
taper sa femme mais plutôt dans les
parties basses pour pas que ça soit etc
etc moi ça me gêne ce enfin ça me gêne
pas ça me donne la nausée ça donne envie
d'oublier alors dernière question est ce
que vous pensez pas et c'était pour ça
que harlem désir a dit ce qu'il a dit au
sujet du qatar est ce que vous pensez
pas que le gouvernement français devrait
prendre ses distances avec cet émirat
moi je suis pas politique de la france
je trouve quand même que c'est toujours
inquiétant qu'un petit pays investissent
autant dans un pays bon c'est pas moi
c'est pas c'est pas mon problème
dans les banlieues voilà par exemple il
ya ce fonds d'investissement dans les
banlieues où c'est un peu inquiétant
c'est à dire que l'état français pas
capable de s'occuper de ses banlieues et
qu'il faut demander un état de 200 les
qatari 20 millions 700 mille habitants
c'est ça qui me gêne voilà j'ai pour toi
c'est qu'il faut prendre nos distances
avec le qatar c'est très difficile parce
que tout ce que le tableau vous venez
d'écrire montre à quel point tout ça est
un briquet et quel que soit le
gouvernement en place ouais ben laquelle
prend ses distances les distances sont
déjà aboli d'une certaine manière
jean-jacques moi je pense qu'il faut
être resté lucide oui mais je pense que
oui il faut faire très attention c'est
bien mais ce sera le mot de la fin voilà
merci d arreter avec nous votre livre
s'appelle terroristes et sept piliers la
déraison chez lattès et si en tête des
ventes en plus
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes toujours en compagnie ne
jamais de vos grades
jean-jacques bande à
antoine de caunes
nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20 heures ce soir françois gabart
bonsoir bonsoir depuis le 27 janvier
dernier votre rêve est devenu réalité
à même pas 30 ans vous êtes le
navigateur le plus rapide de l'histoire
sur cette course autour du monde en
solitaire sans assistance et sans escale
le vendée globe bref vous êtes déjà une
légende
vous nous raconterez notre histoire à 20
heures jacquel maintenant gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
oh
[Applaudissements]
savez gaspard
ouais super d'ici à deux mois en mer
sans ramener un poisson je veux pas
l'exclure
[Applaudissements]
et
cette semaine alors qu'est-ce que tu as
comme infos déjà périmé alors premières
salles de shoot va ouvrir je ne vois pas
le problème je dirais salles de shoot
c'est quoi c'est une pharmacie sans les
produits inefficaces
alors dans la foulée gilbert collard
voyez le vergès à l'aïoli propose
d'ouvrir des salles de crimes de viols
et de vols il ya un peu en retard
collard ça existe déjà ça s'appelle une
prison
internationale le mali bon alors la
guerre est gagnée c'était un peu
prévisible quand même on n'allait quand
même pas perdre contre des gars qui
savent pas se dessiner tout seul une
carte postale de l'unicef
enfin le jour où on perdra contre le
mali nous restera plus qu'à nommer
duflot gouvernement
oui ça c'est déjà fait
alors en guise de victoire au mali
françois hollande s'est vu offrir un
chameau
il a pas réagir il n'a pas réagi même
quand on gagne on arrive à se faire
humilier
on a beau critiquer l'impérialisme
occidental à un moment on devrait aussi
s'insurger contre le profond manque
d'intérêt que nous portent les pays
pauvres
offrir un chameau un français ils ont
déjà ouvert un livre de géo les maliens
ils croient quoi qu'en france on a des
crocodiles dans la seine et des
éléphants dans les garrigues
non mais sans blague mais la prochaine
fois qu'un dirigeant du sel nous au frh
amont devrait lui livrer illico un ours
polaire
en plus je veux dire comme symbole le
chameau un animal qui peut rester un
mois sans boire bombe ce pas on les
libère d'un tas de débiles coranique et
nous en guise de remerciement et nous
offre une gourde qui crottes quoi
je crois de façon le seul avantage cette
intervention au mali c'est que
vigipirate est en alerte maximale et ça
c'est ma vie j pirate je suis à fond
pour comme ça pour une fois que ce pays
a trouvé une façon intelligente de
fliquer les fonctionnaires de la sncf
savait comment on recrute un soldat de
vigipirate c'est on a réfléchi mais pour
toi c'est trop dangereux tombouctou
économie
alors microsoft a décidé de lancer un
smartphone bon marché pour l'afrique
on n'arrête pas le progrès reste plus
qu'à inventer l'adaptateur secteur qui
se branche directement dans le tas de
sable
culture
selon johnny la gauche encourage la
médiocrité ils auraient quand même pu
trouver une façon plus classe de dire
que ça l'avait fait chier de bosser avec
obispo et chedid
alors bon que la gauche sans courage la
médiocrité c'est une évidence il ya qu'à
voir dans quel état se trouve la droite
culture toujours alors non rap enfin je
voulais mettre sur la rubrique culture
mais le rap c'est bien plus que ça c'est
de la culture c'est aussi du sport de la
religion est pas mal de handicap
bref deux balles ont été tirées sur la
voiture du rappeur la fouine alors ça
s'est passé à saint maur des fossés
comme on a le bronx qu'on mérite à
saint-maur-des-fossés c'est un peu
harlem avec des magasins de moquette
saint maclou
il n'y a pas de mort d'homme c'est ça ça
reste du gangsta rap à la française on
peut pas tes gesticulations d'un videur
de boîte avec la logistique du val de
marne on parle d'un règlement de comptes
je me demande bien ce que deux rappeurs
peuvent régler comme compte en france à
part un dossier aux assedic ou le vol
d'un dictionnaire des synonymes
après je
comprends que la fouine accuse le coup
c'est vrai qu'avec le nombre de disques
yvan on se demande s'il arrivera à payer
sa facture chez carglass
[Applaudissements]
autre fait divers danièle evenou en
maillot de bain sur tf1 au delà
oui je ne commente pas la télé mais
quand il ya des vraies infos je pense
qu'on peut pas passer à côté lors
l'émission s'appelle splash le concept
lancé des célébrités de premier plan
qui plonge dans une piscine bon on a mis
une piscine parce que si on avait mis
une cuvette des chiottes les vedettes se
serait peut-être douter de quelque chose
dans splash c'est un peu la bouche à les
goûts télévisuels du has been
franchouillard c'est vraiment du
recyclage à côté le loft une émission
d'arte est comme
moi j'avais un autre concept s'appelle
bim bam boum c'est comme splash mais
avec une piscine vide
sport
football alors révélation d'une vaste
affaire de matches truqués alors il
paraît que ça concerne pas la france ben
c'est normal vu le niveau intellectuel
nos joueurs c'est beaucoup trop complexe
à monter
c'est pas dit
je sais que ça fait un peu cliché
d'illustrer cette idée par une photo de
ribéry mais je vous jure il suffit
d'écouter 15 secondes pour se rend
compte qu'en fait non c'est possible
alors cette révélation s'accompagne de
forts soupçons de dopage dans le milieu
du foot pas en ligue française c'est pas
long tu m'étonnes celui en france pour
tenir le coup c'est pas celui que tu
joues un match qui doit se doper c'est
celui qui le regarde
high tech
récemment la police a découvert 50 mille
images pédophiles dans l'ordinateur d'un
commerçant à toulon alors bon le tipi
s'est défendue a dit oui mais bon j'ai
consulté des sites une ou deux fois elle
aurait pu trouver autre chose contre moi
quand je consulte en ligne mon compte à
l'ubs est ce je me retrouve pas avec
50000 photo de jérôme cahuzac à poil sur
sordide ce bébé mort dans le ventre de
sa mère faute de place pour le faire
accoucher à la maternité alors c'est
vrai que c'était beaucoup mobilisé les
gens très triste les un petit mais
pourquoi pourquoi la couche face est
unanime gagne à tout ça le truc
classique quoi et ben moi j'ai compté le
nombre de mois qui séparent
l'accouchement de l'acte et j'en suis
arrivé à la conclusion qu'en terme de
karma ce n'était pas idéal de copuler le
soir de l'élection de flamby
alors peut-être une bonne nouvelle pour
terminer et on a une vraiment la vitesse
sur le périph va passer de 80 à 70 km
heure chouette enfin pouvoir profiter du
paysage
alors
mais suivre la q2 l'émission et réagir
sur twitter via le compte les terriens
et le hashtag slt on passe maintenant à
notre invité du samedi 20 heures
françois gabart bonsoir vous êtes né le
23 mars
1983 à saint-michel d'entragues dans les
charentes votre père est dentiste et
votre mère magistrate à angoulême alors
j'ai déjà pressé avant même de naître
puisque vous avez manqué de naître avec
deux mois d'avancé vrai et à la
maternelle vous prenez un an d'avant ce
que vous garderez jusqu'à la fin de
votre scolarité c'est aussi vrai donc un
mec rapide bah ouais je vais avoir envie
d'aller voir ce qui se passait dehors
dans le monde et voilà alors que les six
ans lorsque vos parents décident de
traverser l'atlantique aller retour en
famille avec vous donc à l'isq à 9 ans
et cécile qui a trois ans et vous dites
cette traversée c'est l'acte fondateur
de ma vie quoi bah c'est là où j'ai
découvert le bateau c'est là où j'ai
découvert la mer on s'imprègne je pense
de sensations de de plein de choses qui
nous font que qu'à la fin je crois qu'on
a tous les trois été touché par par ça
et sept mois derrière j'ai continué à
faire du bateau ainsi que je vous partez
avec vos parents au même moment par la
première édition du vendée globe qui a
été gagné par titouan lamazou alors
pendant la traversée vous avez six ans
et vous passez votre temps à grimper au
mât pour surveiller l'horizon et vous
développez un rapport quasi animale avec
le bateau ça facile après les choses
quand derrière on fait on est seul on
est en mer mais vous passionnez
également pour la technicité des voiles
vous passez des heures à faire des
noeuds marins les yeux bandés
ou alors avec les mains dans le dos ou
alors avec une seule main des fois y'a
pas grand chose à faire donc bah s'amuse
avec mes soeurs là on trouve des jeux
des jeux d'enfants compte cinq alors
durant la traversée vous prenez
possession de la next petit bateau que
compte hier derrière d'abord à la rame
puis au moteur 1 et en arrivant en
floride vous découvrez que des amis de
vos parents ont comme annexes non pas
aux diack à mothern un voilier un petit
optimist offs i way voilà là vous
commencez à tirer des bords donc à l'âge
de 7 ans c'est vrai qu'on est super
content on est super fiers on a six
attendait tout seul sur un bateau c'est
une certaine fierté de la même façon
après les bateaux grand 10 mai à cette
époque là dans dix ans
avec un bateau tout seul c'est vrai on
est le roi du monde quoi alors de retour
en france votre père vous pouvez
inscrire votre premier bateau pour
naviguer alors là c'est dans la banlieue
d'angoulême sur une marin faut dire que
c'est pas terrible y'a pas devant vous
êtes dans la pétole tout le temps là
c'est pas mal pour apprendre en faire à
faire du bateau ce qu on est sur un plan
d'eau intérieur comme ça du coup le vent
est assez assez aléatoire du coup bas
pour sentir le vent c'est une bonne
école en 1997 donc j'avais 14 ans vous
êtes champion de france d'optimistes et
à la fin de vos études vous annoncer à
vos parents que vous voulez faire de la
course votre métier en fait tout un tas
d'école et ses devoirs et le 10 novembre
dernier vous prenez le départ du
septième vendée globe toujours pressé 1
vous partez avant le coup de canon
vous êtes obligés de revenir et de
reprendre le départ ça devait être c'est
ma nature ce soir je suis j'ai
certainement envie d'aller un peu de
l'avant de temps je fais assez vite dans
mon parcours vous dit cette course le
vendée globe c'est un calvaire c'est une
punition c'est de la folie et on va voir
comment ça se passe d'abord la fatigue
alors à chaque virage il faut équilibrer
les masses sur le bateau cela il faut
déplacer entre 5 800 kg de matériel 1
plusieurs fois par jour en fait on
toutes les masses qui sont embarqués les
voiles le matériel de rechange les
outils pour réparer la nourriture nos
vêtements donc tout ça ça représente un
peu de poids forcément et ça
représentait ménager un appartement de
50 mètres carrés tout seul en une demi
heure voilà c'est à peu près ça sauf que
le vent tourne et fort des ménages et le
lendemain et puis ça rend retourne
lareau déménager c'est un peu la
grand-voile 590 kg la grand-voile
comment vous faites vous portez tous à
tous âges non on a une drisse donc un
bouquin qui tire la maca et puis après
on a des systèmes de winch et balance
qui permet de quand même qu occupe
l'ailé l'effort mais bon quand ça
décuple efforts se dire qu'il faut
pousser plus longtemps donc ça s'appelle
le matossage oui alors fait aussi monter
en haut du mak 29 m ça peut rien avec
des creux de quatre mètres quoi il faut
tenir now bah ouais quand ça bouge là où
ça bouge beaucoup en fait c'est que ça
fait limite vite levier donc ça vous à
une statue elle dit fils et d'insécurité
quand même un truc ah bah oui de façon
moins pas on monte accroché avec du
matériel d'alpinisme
d'avancé corriger les enseignes parce
que je pense que je vais le faire
dans quatre ans
alors il ya aussi l'humidité on faisait
toujours trempé quoi bah c'est pas très
vite l'eau salée sur les mains sur le
visage et le sel d'abord le sel faut
bien comprendre que ces attaques la peau
assez rapidement ça c'est un problème et
ça que là on est on est dans un milieu
qui est humide un forcément déçu parce
qu est ce que vous pouvez prendre des
douches doucement on peut mais c'est pas
évident c'est pas évident parce que bah
quand on est dans un registre course on
n'a pas forcément le temps déjà la
possibilité alors on fabrique notre
douce on en fabrique pas non plus mais
pas de 100 litres d'eau tous les jours
il ya le bruit parce que le bateau il
est allé en carbone il ya les vagues qui
tapent sans harek quoi contre la coque
24 heures sur 24 un peu comme métier
enfermé dans le tambour d'une machine à
laver ouais c'est à peu près ça et c'est
ça au delà du bruit dans le tambour de
la machine à laver sa tournée sadournin
plus et ça parce que j'ai vraiment
trouvé difficile c'est que le bateau
tape en permanence et bouge en
permanence et du coup bah on peut pas
être assis comme l'a tranquillement a
pas bougé on est en mouvement en
permanence torture si jamais on n'a pas
cette fois cette envie énorme comme
j'avais de faire cette course ça peut
vraiment devenir ont fait depuis très
très dur quand même fait un tueur alors
on peut pas mettre des boules quiès
parce qu'il faut sans être à l'écouté du
bateau c'est ça aussi le problème est le
bruit quelque part c'est un m face à un
ami horse et c'est difficile parce qu'on
ne s'accordant un niveau sonore qui perd
élevé et en même temps dans ce bazar
dans ce vacarme un peu son honneur il
faut vraiment écouté parce que on a
beaucoup d'informations qui viennent par
le son est donc dans ce grand bazar il
ya des fois des bruits pour connaître
quelque chose d'anormal en fait qui ne
donne aucune information à sortir sur le
pont parce qu'il ya un groupe petit à
petit et une volée qui s'est déchiré
fabien quelque chose donc c'est
l'oreille et est vraiment une amie au
royal sommeil en fait des petites plages
de sommeil de combien a pas beaucoup et
on vous fait pas beaucoup les 12 heures
de sommeil sais tu combien on dort par
ba 25 minutes 1h 2h faire des siestes et
alors il ya des gens je passe chez vous
est arrivé qu'ils ont des hallucinations
à force si on aura vraiment away ça
qu'on a déjà lu par exemple il ya des
mecs qui qui se réveille qui descendent
du bateau en croyant qu'ils sont au port
bah moi je sais qu'à chaque fois que
j'ai eu des à lui et à chaque fois j'ai
déjà lu j'ai déjà je m'accroche ça évite
d'avoir des soucis et puis bon c'est une
source d'information quand tu dis ben là
je commence à voir
je commence à voir quelqu'un alors tu es
tout seul qu'il faut essayer d'aller se
reposer un visa légal collabore alors
j'étais parti en pensant ne pas avoir du
tout d'alcool et mes parents m'avaient
mis de deux petites bouteilles de
petites mignonnette de pineau des
charentes ouais et que j'ai pris pas mal
de plaisir à voir c'était sympa rue vous
dopez pas dans la voie là bas moi
personnellement nancéen exclure d'autres
non mais ça je crois pas je pense non
parce que c'est pas dans la philosophie
des marins vraiment c'est fois c'est un
état d'esprit en fait en bateau on est
on est en équilibre quelque part on a en
charge des équilibres en permanence et
je crois pas je pense que ça a créé du
déclin de l'énergie mais ont fumé un
pétard quand il fait beau quand même
temps ça fait partie des produits
dopants le
et donc on a des contrôles
antidopage y'a pas encore d'antidopage
ici en a régulièrement et moi depuis que
je suis ado depuis que je fais de la
voile et de la voilà au niveau je fais
attention à ça parce que je suis j'ai
des flashs des amis qui fut en effet des
joints et je fais attention parce que
même en étant fumeur pour un jeu un peu
c'est un déclic six qualifiés ah bah oui
bien sûr je le ferai pas assez
voilà et le sexe alors comment on fait
vous avez internet de regarder youporn
n'ont pas exactement voilà c'est vrai
avec internet on fait tout mon accroc le
sait maintenant on va pas vous charcuter
des volumes et puis elle est grosse
galère alors au cinquième jour vous
découvrez que de l'eau de mer s'est
infiltré dans votre moteur ça veut dire
plus d'électricité 1 donc plus de pilote
automatique etc et là vous démonter tout
vous faites tremper dans l'essence et
après vous avez quand même pas d'huile
alors vous prenez ce que vous appelez la
mayonnaise tire le mélange d'eau et
d'huile qui est donc dans le moteur vous
faites chauffer pour que l'eau s'évapore
et dé récupérer l'huile ses mac gyver
quoi ouais ça a un peu du mal c'est sûr
à gond labadié des moments faisait
brouillé avec ce qu'on a c'est qu'on n'a
pas tous les outils etc un mécano valoir
dans un garage on n'a pas non plus que
la connaissance d'un mécano puisqu'on
fait un peu de mécanique un peu
d'électricité on a géré la chose
ça aide d'être ingénieur ça j'en suis
bien bien vécu bien sûr quand vous
démonter le moteur énorme en pleine mer
avec les vagues ça bouge dans tous les
sens il fait un huit jours la course
continue faut continuer à avancer avec
le bateau on n'essaye pas de continuer à
avancer le plus vite possible que les
autres se rendent pas compte qu'on a un
problème
et c'est vrai que je faisais pas le
malin ce moment là aussi parce qu'en
plus c'est le début de course et eu
beaucoup d'abandons et on n'a pas envie
que ce soit ce sera notre tour alors
conclusion à vous dites je me suis
surpris avec cette course je ne savais
pas que j'avais cette énergie là vous
êtes étonnés vous même quand même ouais
on s'étonne nous mêmes c'est ça tous les
jours on s'étonne un peu parce que c'est
difficile on fait face et puis un moment
donné on se dit le deuxième jour enfin
si ça continue comme ça j'ai pas tenir
puis ça continue puis ben on y va on
continue on continue la force de
continuer à donner jusqu'à l'arrivée et
ça que je me suis surpris moi même mais
par la capacité à négocier stade montois
pour cent soixante mille euros c'est
beaucoup d'argent mais enfin c'est pas
non plus un
et c'est pas ce matin exactement et au
final c'est important de gagner le
gagner la course
je vais pas super content de l'avoir
gagné évidemment mais j'étais pas partie
que pour la gagner j'étais parti pour
faire un tour du monde vous pour essayer
de terminer ce tour du monde vivent
quelque chose de fort je pense que
j'aurai aussi été super heureux en
terminant 3e 4e 5e et c'est assez c'est
un peu la cerise sur le gâteau le voyage
vous à transformer souvenez de
l'histoire de moi et tessier qui avait
fait le tour du monde qui faisait en
outre ensemble c'est une évidence mais
moi je vois le voile ce tour du monde
comme un moment en fait on a des moments
d'émotion et de des moments de vie qui
sont très très forts comme on peut avoir
dans une vie entre guillemets normale en
5 10 ou 15 ans et du coup je pense que
tout ça est condensée et quelque part on
prend de l'expérience je pense d'une
manière un peu plus forte que
normalement et je pense que du coup
ouais je pense qu'on vit un peu avant sa
fin c'est sûr tout cas c'est le
sentiment que jean jacques toux une
question politique sur est de poser en
donnant une classe toute simple et cette
compétition formidable avec armel le
cléac'h vous vous êtes parler pendant la
course certains moments par radio ouais
en étant en contact vhf donc on a un peu
causés par vhf après trois très
rapidement on est tellement en
compétition que on n'a pas grand chose à
dire qu'il soit le snte on fait
attention dans notre communication il
est la terre ce qu'on fait attention à
ce qu'on dit pour pas donner de
l'information à l'adversaire qui
pourrait utiliser donc du coup
maintenant tous les vacations même si le
skipper adversaires et l'écoutent pas ya
des gens à terre qui peuvent l'écouter
qui peuvent après lui dira il avait tel
voile ou machin qui pourrait lui servir
on vous attention on ne pouvait pas se
permettre de donner des informations que
vous êtes passés devant pas dû avoir
donné non pas du tout parce que c'est
déjà c'est un ami parce quelqu'un que je
respecte beaucoup et
comme les animateurs télé
ça n'a rien
et alors
vous avez un côté quand même le excusez
moi mais le blond de gad elmaleh c est
parfait et par rapport à des kersauson
ou à des maîtres comme ça qu'ils étaient
beaucoup plus c'est un peu nadal qua non
ouais je
pense que c'est là c'est vrai que le
métier se professionnalise et des
bateaux qui sont de plus en plus
technique le niveau sportif augmente
donc un moment donné où il faut au
minimum de rigueur pour arriver à faire
tout ce
qui est génial
merci matrimoniale voilà c'était salut
les terriens
tous amis
avec jeannette bourgrab pour ma
république se meurt chez grasset jean
jacques bourdin lamatina games est
désormais sur rmc découverte de 7h à
8h30 est toujours là talent ou politique
bfm rmc
8h30 9h antoine de caunes
soutien nuit des césar marc trévidic
pour terran riche et la teste et
françois gabart merci beaucoup
elle est appelée à cette émission je
vous laisse avec made in groland rendez
vous la semaine prochaine d'ici là sur
canalplus.fr avec en bonus le top des
vannes l'édito de l'aco l'édito des
gréements et gaspard proust salutaire
m
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu